Following in the footsteps of names like the late
Christopher Reeve and Brandon Routh, Henry Cavill
debuted as Superman in 2013. Starring in the
DC Extended Universe-launching "Man of Steel,"
this take on Kal-El was quite different from his
predecessors. His more thoughtful, somber Superman
occupied a dark, moody world, but that didn't
turn all DC fans away. Many came to love Cavill's
approach to the character, which is why he
continued to appear in the DCEU in future films.
In the wake of "Batman v. Superman: Dawn of
Justice" and both cuts of "Justice League,"
Cavill's version of Superman wound up in
limbo. Fans couldn't help but wonder if his
run was over as the DCEU struggled to find
its footing. Then came 2022's "Black Adam,"
where Cavill got one more crack at the part in a
post-credits sequence. One would have to imagine
that this was a sign he was back for the long
haul. However, as we learned on December 14,
2022, this won't be the case as a new
Superman-centric film is developed.
There's certainly an argument to be made
that Henry Cavill never got his proper due
as Superman and should continue as the legendary
DC hero on the silver screen. However, it's
important to face the facts: recasting Superman
is the best way to go at this stage in the game.
In October 2022, James Gunn and Peter
Safran were announced as the leaders of
a new division of Warner Bros. Discovery
called DC Studios. The goal of this group
is to ensure continuity and consistent
quality across most DC Comics-based films,
and television projects. If Gunn and
Safran want to keep the DCU in order,
they must come to accept the fact that with
continuity issues, retcons, and more, it's
past the point of fixing. Therefore, scrapping
everything and starting fresh is their best move.
This means letting Henry Cavill go in favor of
a new Superman actor. After all, Superman isn't
just some minor player. He's Superman. If they
really want to convince fans they're entering a
new-and-improved era of DC media, it would be
counterproductive to bring back the previous
version of their tentpole character to lead the
charge. Besides, it also puts an end to this
strange and frustrating limbo Henry Cavill's
Superman has been trapped in for years now.
Even though it's best for him to leave
the role behind, there's no denying how
much Henry Cavill loves Superman. He went
above and beyond to be the best version
of "The Man of Steel" that he could,
and if the DCU wasn't in the process
of a soft reboot, he could easily remain.
Unfortunately, due to no fault of his own,
Cavill's portrayal just has too much baggage
for him to carry on under Gunn and Safran.
"Now the cameras are waiting at your ship, for
the world to see the holes in the holy. Yes,
the almighty comes clean about
how dirty he is when it counts."
Most of the films he's appeared in have proven
critically divisive, namely "Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice." Many also stem
from the now-defunct Snyderverse:
a string of DCEU entries tied to director
Zack Snyder that, according to Collider,
Warner Bros. Discovery has tried to
distance itself from in recent years.
The "Justice League" CGI upper lip debacle and
dead-end "Black Adam" cameo didn't help either.
So is Henry Cavill destined to never play
Superman again? Maybe, but as comic book
media has proven over the years, it's smart
to never say never. From Michael Keaton as
Batman to Hugh Jackman as Wolverine, legacy
actors returning to their superhero roles is
far from uncommon. Once enough time passes,
the DCU finds its groove with a new Superman,
and a narrative opportunity arises,
perhaps Cavill could return to play
the same version of the beloved hero we've come
to recognize — or one from another timeline.
Then again, with Cavill no longer
playing the main DCU Superman,
that does free him up to take on
another role in the canon. In fact,
the same day his Superman departure was
announced, James Gunn mentioned on Twitter:
"We just had a great meeting with Henry
and we're big fans and we talked about a
number of exciting possibilities
to work together in the future."
"I have so many questions."
Could he be a member of the Green Lantern
Corps? Bizarro? Bat-Mite? Time will tell,
but hopefully, he'll get to sink his
teeth into a new DC role down the line.